The first point is about
the interface design and
the main specifications criterion for
basically creeds
is all application components render
on screen in a responsive manner.
Usable.
Across a modern desktop tablet and
phone browsers.
You want to make sure
the things look good.
>> Especially because you have several
different continents inside of one
application you're going
to be having a google maps.
That's going to show your markers.
And then you have a list view off the
same places that are shown in markers.
As well as a search bar or whatever
that you integrate inside your map.
Which is going to filter that
list view as well as the markers.
So make sure that all these competence
together render in a very responsive
manner, and usable manner, in the sense
that, we don't want your list view to
completely populate your mobile browser
and not be able to view your map.
It can be a toggle element that
you can sort of minimize and
maximize the way you want it to.
Or you can make it responsive and
very relative to the screen size.
>> Since we're talking about
interface design one thing that
I definitely want to say is start
with a mobile first design.
And we say that because it's so
much easier to design.
Take something and make it better,
instead of taking something bigger and
make it small.
And the next one is about
app architecture which says,
code is properly separated based
upon Knockout's best practices.
Following an MVVM pattern,
avoiding updating the dom manually.
Using observables rather than
forcing the brushes manually etc.
So this goes through Knockout and
JavaScript design pattern of
course is going to help a lot.
>> Yeah.
Over here.
>> Now-
>> We can talk a little bit about
the Model-View-ViewModel architecture in
general because that might be a little
complicated to understand the beginning
and how to integrate it in your code.
>> So the Model-View-ViewModel splits
your UI code into three parts.
The model, the view and the view model.
Now these names are self explanatory
the model basically is going to
have all your data it can be
data related your where it is located.
What type of food I think about too.
[LAUGH] Does it serve,
anything that has got any information.
>> Yeah.
>> Is going to go in your data.
>> And this data can be rewritten and
hard coded by yourself when you're
starting to build the application.
So if you're overwhelmed by hey
how do I actually put in this
JSON get a JSON array from
a third party API and
send it to render it in map markers and
so on if you're overwhelmed.
Take one place or two places
hard coded into a JSON object.
You guys know how to create
JSON objects from project two,
so I'm sure you'll know how to do it.
Just put in two places and try to put in
these places inside your map markers.
So your JSON object
is essentially what-.
>> Your login will be.
Now the view,
this usually is basically what you view.
It's the visual representation
of what you see off your data.
So in case of a place,
you're going to see a marker.
So anything that can be
seen goes in your view.
And then the model view or
the view model is the messenger
between your data.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Or the model.
And your view, which is.
>> Yeah.
>> Your visual information.
So any data, or all the data
is taken by this model view,
processed, and then given to the view.
To display it and
render it on the screen.
>> I know that a lot of people would
know it as the model view control,
but yeah.
We call it the model
view-view model pattern.
For Knockout and
that's how Knockout it is built upon.
A little more details on it with
respect to Knockout who would be
that Knockout essentially handles
the view model part of things.
In the sense that it has
a very nice property of data
bindings where you can actually
observe your dom elements
inside your view model
to make changes to it.
Let's say that you have a list
element coded up in your HTML.
So you have a dom element
that's in a full list and
you don't know how many list
items go into that list.
Everything's going to be based upon
what you're going to retrieve from an
API and then send it to the front end.
So how do I know if the list contains
ten elements or five or just one?
So what you can do is, you can add a
data bind property to your list element,
and this can be accessed
inside your JavaScript
by calling the ko.observable function.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
what that is going to do is Anytime.
So you give an ID inside your data bank.
So whenever you call that ko.observable
with the ID passed into it
as whatever dom element
you're getting from the HTML.
It's going to track that
element immediately.
And it can make changes to that
element you can add more data into it.
You can retrieve what the current
data is inside that list element.
So it's basically to update the dom and
retrieve data from the dom.
And so what you will be essentially
working on is the view model portion
necessarily.
And I know that model is going to
be just a simple data object.,
Jason object that.
>> At least to start out with.
>> Yeah, to start out with.
So it's always going to be
something that you code or
you will be getting an array or
JSON object from your third party API.
So yeah that's how Knockout works and
that's what you should
basically keep in mind.
>> The next part is that it's
asynchronous HTTP usage.
And this is where we see
a lot of projects not meet
specifications on their
first time around.
And we can talk a little
bit in depth about it, but
you want to make sure that
you're using Google Maps API.
That's the basic requirement.
>> Yeah.
>> You want to make sure you're using
at least one third party data API.
And make sure Places, Google Places and
Google Street View do
not fall under this.
Both of these APIs are actually
a part of Google Maps.
>> Yeah, they're like a library
under Google Maps API.
So it's great if you integrate it but
we would want another third party
API apart from the Google ones.
>> And there are some interesting
ones that we have seen.
A lot of people use the usual and
Instagram and
>> And
Wikipedia the full square Flicker.
>> So you can use any third party API
has long as it has documentation that we
can read and understand.
>> Yeah also that some of these
third party APIs might have
a lot of odd stuff to do like
authentication and authorization.
I know that a lot of people have
tried using YouTube API and
YouTube API definitely needs it.
A lot and you have tutorials for
it in the Google developers website, so
if you asked.
If you guys would ask me.
How do I learned these third party APIs?
Just go to their own documentation
Yelp has a developer's page
where they talk about
their search API and
other APIs that you can take and
sort of like the attributes that
you need to query them using
to get places and restaurants.
Or with a particular location or so on.
So definitely if you want to get started
with an API that you have no experience
with, what I would do is just go read
their developer documentation and
then find tutorials good,
trustworthy tutorials around it.
A very important point is,
whenever you're using a third party API,
you need to enable cross origin resource
sharing for some of these APIs.
So make sure that, so
that your app is actually able
to access other APIs data from
other APIs so definitely go and
look into enable pause.org
to make sure that you
don't have to handle any additional
condition in using those APIs so
do, do please do read documentation.
>> I think in the next big part
of this is the whole asynchronous
all data requests are retrieved
asynchronous manner.
And I think this part is done
with the model view-view modify.
But where a lot of students
stumble is in the event of
a failed data retrieval
errors are handled.
And we do explain what error
handling what we mean by that.
When an API cannot load its data,
you either want to pop
up an error message that says hey,
sorry I'm not working, come back later.
Or you want to have a project, or
your UI should not get
affected by data retrieval.
So an easy way to check what
happens when you block,
as a sort of an API, is to go and
play around with your hosts files.
>> Yeah.
There are two main methods
to check it using host
files as Carrie was mentioning,
and there's another one which is by
blocking your Internet connection.
>> I'm going to go sudo nano/
>> [LAUGH]
>> etc/hosts?
>> Yeah.
And this is what will open up and I had
just checked this like a minute back.
So it's not asking me for my password.
>> Yeah.
>> Otherwise it would.
What you want to do is
have just # custom.
And then you're going
to add a local host ID.
>> Yeah.
>> And then
>> [CROSSTALK]
Maps.googleapis.com
>> Or
any other API that you
might want to block.
>> Yeah.
>> En.wikipedia.org
>> Mm-hm.
>> And once you do this you want
to hit CTRL and ALT together and
then hit Enter and what this is
going to do is basically block.
My API is now-
>> And
then you can open up your application.
And what Google Maps usually does,
is it just gives a gray screen.
So it doesn't give you any error,
it doesn't look very pretty
in your application, just gives
you a bright gray screen saying.
And what happens usually
is there is an error in
the google developer, Chrome's console,
where it says Google is not defined.
So all you need to do is
add a condition that would
actually handle when
Google is undefined.
So when Google is undefined show
an error, render an image that
says something or something else that,
hey sorry our app is not
functioning right now please come back
and check later or something like that.
And you can check it with disabling your
internet connection as well I believe
I think that should work as well.
So those are the ways to sort of check
how your application is reacting
when a failure occurs.
>> And the first one we talked
about is map functionality and
a map representation of
identified locations is provided.
Runs error free and is presented
in a usable and responsive manner.
We keep seeing this usable and
responsive manner,
which takes you back to
the interface design.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Start on a small screen device, and
go up to a large screen device.
You basically want to see those markers.
>> Yeah.
>> We need those markers
to be clickable.
And change their styling
when they're clicked on.
My favorite one was, or
I shouldn't say my favorite one.
But the bobbing one is the most
common one that I've seen.
>> Yeah, it depends.
>> You can change
the color of the marker.
It can be a subtle change,
it doesn't have to go from red to black.
>> Yeah
>> Or
anything at least need to
see something of the change.
>> Make sure that you're
filtering your markers
at the same time updating
your list view as well.
So that should be responsive you don't
want all your markers to show up
even when you're filtering the list or
searching a specific place in the list.
That's not a very usable
design of your application,
if you have to go through
each of your markers.
To actually find the place
you were looking for.
So just make sure that your
search functionality the keyword
updates your list as
well as your markers.
>> Vice versa would also be good in that
when you click on a marker it somehow
highlights the place that you have
clicked on in your list view.
>> That's right, yeah.
So.
All right.
This is an easy one.
No location details functionality,
functionality providing additional data,
data location is provided
runs error free.
And it's presented in the usable
responsive manner so we really want
you to get responsive design
with this project obviously.
And we want to see some additional
info provided about the location.
You can choose how you
want to implement it.
The most implementation is
when you click on a marker
it opens an info window,
with something more about the place.
Maybe their phone number.
It's phone number, Yelp address.
>> Address.
>> Location details, yeah anything.
>> Even if you give the latitude and
longitude it's
>> It's.
>> Yeah.
>> Fine.
I know some people attach like links to
YouTube videos or Instagram pictures and
so on.
That's going above and beyond.
It's awesome, but
start out small all the time and
then go start enhancing your project,
is what I would say.
>> But even with a third party API,
implement Google Maps.
The way you would want
it implemented first.
Before you jump on it and
get on mistake things of adding
another third party API.
The search functionality has a search
function is provided runs error free and
is presented in the usable
new response manner.
That's again the search
function is more like
a filtering operation from your lists.
So if I have Anna and Annabel,
when I type Anna, I want to be
able to see both Anna and Annabel.
And the moment I type that b,
it's wonderful, Anna goes away and
I can see just Annabel.
Yeah, we actually don't give you
guidelines on how smart your
search is but we want to see
some kind of search, right.
Just if you want to put a full
keyword and search it you can do it.
If you want just by a single
letter You can do it that way.
But we want to see that
filtering is going on.
And that is going to in turn,
trigger your markers and
your list to be updated is what
we want to see get out of it.
And we also want you to code
in more than one place.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Since we want you to
be able to search and
show that hey I have-
>> Unless
>> Ten places.
>> List with more than one element.
>> Exactly.
I have ten places and
I type this letter and
one of them show up or
five of them show up.
So we definitely do want to test that
functionality at If you're going to be
using only one phase that sort
of makes it difficult for
us to even like check if your
functionality works fine.
It's just make sure that
returns multiple places.
>> Well, even if you have a few quiz and
buy something that i may not
see in someone's list view.
I usually just go with my name.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If that doesn't show up I and
can see that your list
is functioning ok.
You can definitely, If you want
to go above and beyond implement.
X completion.
>> Yeah, autocomplete,
yeah, that's right.
>> Autocomplete,
we've seen some of those projects now
really Going to play around with.
Keyboard shortcuts,
would be another one.
The next part of rubric is basically
talking about the list view.
A list view or some other variation of
browsing with the content, is provided,
runs error free, and is presented in
a useable and responsible manner.
You can choose to have
a difficult list view.
>> Yeah.
>> If you want.
But it is in double quotes.
So if you think of a creative way of
representing of all locations that you
have beyond the markers, please go ahead
do that who'd love to see that project.
>> Yeah
>> I think that's.
It's pretty easy to understand point.
The next few ones are, again you
are going to be best on good quality,
you have been getting good reviews now.
So, we have added that
detail to our evaluation.
>> Yeah, mm-hm.
>> So make sure your code is clean.
You have commented.
You don't have commented
code left in your project.
And I understand sometimes,
it's just nice to have.
I had it working this way.
But remember, you're using GitHub.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
you have version controlling in build.
And you can go back and
you can go forward, but whatever.
If you're doing you can host that thing
on a completely different branch,
because what we are looking for
is on the master branch.
And production quality code
tends to be on the master bench.
>> Yeah.
>> And that is
reason why we want to check
on the master branch.
The last one is the readme.
Something that you have been
doing since project one.
This is, the second and
last thing that you'll be doing
it in this nano degree program.
Make sure you tell us how
to run your application.
If you need us to unlock it,
have instructions for that.
Most of you haven't been or most of the
projects that I've seen just in his unit
somewhere on the public internet and
it's really nice to see these projects.
>> Yeah yeah.
And don't forget build tools as well
if you want to go above and beyond.
You have learned a lot
of useful techniques and
optimization efforts in project four.
You do want it, you're going to
have a ton of JavaScript, CSS.
Code, I bet, in this application.
So, it's always important to
make them render blocking.
Make sure that they are all minified,
and
don't have extra spaces that could
potentially make your storage, as well.
Do a higher value song.
Just make sure that all your
code is optimized if you can.
Of course this is optional, I'm not
like pressing it on you guys to do it,
but it's definitely a good practice and
you can sort of like.
Remember, you can, if you want to sort
of refresh your mind from Project Four
and be like I want to try using grunt or
gulp again, you know, on this project.
>> Yeah.
>> And it seems like I have all this,
like, JavaScript file that can,
that I can concatenate and minify,
and then Use them all to host my page,
and it will be more efficient and
faster when I do that.
Go ahead and do it.
Add it in the readme,
and just make sure that you send
us a readable copy as well,
because we definitely want to be seeing
how you've written your JavaScript code
and I know that a lot of people have
been asking me hey I'm so overwhelmed,
I'm unstuck at this point where
I have my Google Maps filled in.
I don't know how to go forward.
I don't know how to make things work.
So what I would say
is we are looking for
knockout only when you make changes
to your list view, or only when
you make changes to filtering your JSON
array that you get back from an API.
So, Google Maps is a view
model by itself, so
you don't need to put that
inside your view model class.
I know that a lot of students
have this question of,
hey, I don't know where Google Maps
goes exactly into the MVC pattern.
>> Don't worry about
Google Maps basically.
>> Yeah.
And you don't need to worry about
using data bind on your marker
objects or anything of that sort.
All you need to worry about is,
whatever ways that you
manipulate this array of objects that
you are going to show in your list item
should be using observables, and
should be in your view model.
And the same filtering or
whatever mechanism you do and
get the filtered list,
make sure that it's always written
like reflected in your google maps API,
so make sure that your list view and
your google maps API are in sync or
they are rendering all the places.
But you don't need to worry about
integrating data bindings and
do a google map object.
That is going to get complicated
when you start out doing.
I have not tried that, personally,
and I'm going to be open about it.
So I don't go how well that
would work or if it would work.
So you don't need to worry about
applying knockouts principles-
>> Mm-hm.
>> On your Google maps.
Just make sure that outside of it,
whatever DOM element that you
create outside of the Google maps
need to be updated dynamically
during your run time.
And need to use Knockout.
So definitely go with
that approach in mind.
And if you want, all you need to worry
about is to set Google maps aside and
get data from third party API's and
be able to render that data
unless you're using Knockout.
That should be your first objective.
And then integrate it all
together if it gets overwhelming.
>> You can start out with a Google map,
I would also recommend in a Google
map in their project too.
>> Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
>> So, going back and
seeing what was done over there,
might be a good place to start.
>> Definitely.
You have to create documentation or.
>> Yes, so go ahead and
just read up on that.
It's a great place to start and then
you can start with a map that's tiny.
And then work on making it bigger.
>> Yeah, exactly.
More functionality added into it and,
yeah we do have a lot of
medium through which you can communicate
with your peers and with your coaches.
So feel free to leverage that as well.
>> I bet just the way
we are happy about it,
the student who submits this
also is happy about it.
>> And if you've come to Project Five,
it means it's a great achievement for
you guys.
>> Definitely.
>> You've learned a lot,
and you're here, and
that's why you're At that point so
do not get frustrated.
It can be overwhelming but
it's how you take it it's going to be
a lot of learning experience for you.
It might be frustrating but
it's going to happen
you're going to get a great satisfaction
and you actually see these up and
running and I'm sure that you
guys can get there for sure.